[Music]
High time now tonight for the Hannity
hot seat and tonight we're joined by a
republican who opposed Kevin McCarthy's
bid for speaker on every single ballot
that is Colorado congresswoman Lauren
bobert and she says negotiations with
McCarthy have been ongoing since the
summer but that her demands are not
being taken seriously now meanwhile
Kevin McCarthy's Camp is now reportedly
trying to determine which of the 20
votes against him are because of a
policy disagreement versus a personal
Vendetta here now with reaction is
congresswoman bobert now Congressman let
me let me you tweet a town hall quoted
you today saying the president you said
complimentary things about President
Trump needs to tell Kevin McCarthy that
sir you do not have the votes it's time
to withdraw
let me turn the tables congresswoman
Kevin McCarthy is 202 three votes your
site has 20. so if I'm going to use your
words and your methodology and your math
uh isn't it time for you to pack it in
in your side to pack it in considering
he has over 200 and you have 20.
Sean I understand the frustration I
promise you but I'm not frustrated you
didn't answer my question we are hearing
we are hearing about frustrated who are
still voting with Kevin McCarthy you're
not answering my question of what we're
doing and they're cheering us on so
there are more for us than are against
us and they are waiting for Kevin to
keep
um
certainly frustrated by I'm frustrated
by you not answering a direct question
you said to president Trump you you said
earlier today that President Trump needs
to tell Kevin McCarthy you don't have
the votes can I finish candidate to
elect it can I finish the house you
don't have the votes and it's time to
withdraw he has 203 your side has 20.
why is it time for him to withdraw and
not you when he has so many more votes
well Sean he needs 218 and he does not
have 218. we've been trying out in
private as you said for months but Kevin
McCarthy didn't even want to listen to
us until his disappointing midterms we
all want a unified party but this isn't
chaos it's a functioning constitutional
republic when everything is said and
done okay I like this Republicans will
be stronger and better prepared to lead
than we ever after before I believe our
founding fathers intended and this is
showing yesterday you voted are working
our votes aren't just an uh
congresswoman I'd ask it out to
filibuster yesterday you voted and Jim
Jordan was your choice uh today it was
Byron Donald so he was your choice uh
tomorrow I don't know who you're going
to vote for but the bottom line is you
still only have 20 votes let me ask you
this Kevin McCarthy proving that we're
open to a menu of options you're proving
that 20 people don't want Kevin McCarthy
at this time but my question to you is
this proving that there are many options
my question to you is did you see poor
Kevin McCarthy's commitments to America
and do you not believe that he's going
to follow through on his written
promises
commitment to America is not as strong
as I would like it to be and we have
been working on the rules to change the
structure of how Washington DC is is run
and operated Sean you know more than
anybody how broken this town is this is
something that we have an opportunity to
rebuild to restructure congresswoman he
talked about the right leadership to do
that border security energy Independence
debt reduction earmarked forward the
Texas built border plan
and then well he's willing to bring back
the the exact plan that worked under
Donald Trump and then he also has
pledged investigations into the FBI and
doj the influence peddling of the Biden
family the origins of covet and Anthony
fauci the withdrawal from Afghanistan my
question is Right speaker do you support
it's not going to be Kevin McCarthy do
you support all of those agenda items he
promised
of course I do but I do not trust Kevin
McCarthy at this point to deliver on
those promises especially when I go into
good faith negotiations with him and
then he comes out and lies about what
those conversations were um saying that
members demanded that's your
characterization he's not here to answer
you want
so let me ask you this one member in
private because he won't apologize to
him in public for spreading lies about
that meeting here's my question so you
and others fought hard for a motion to
vacate with only five Republicans able
to trigger that that that motion Uh
Kevin McCarthy didn't want to give it to
you but he did give it to you in the end
to me that's kind of an insurance policy
he's hitting all the way he did not sure
he he gave you what you asked for and
one of the things that I've been asking
people I'm asking you tonight who is
your final choice for speaker and if you
can't get more than let's say 30 votes
will you follow your own advice uh that
you were asking Donald Trump in
withdrawal
there are certainly names that are being
floated around and hey maybe I should
nominate president Donald J Trump
tomorrow but Sean I I did watch your
show last it's a game show like we're
going to pick on this Motion
Picture Jim Jordan one day Donald's the
other day Trump the next day this motion
to vacate because he did not give us
this motion to vacate I'm showing
there's a a whole consensus of other
candidates I'm trying to understand
solution to vacate Sean you need to
understand that that Kevin McCarthy did
not give us my hard Red Line This is a
century old centuries no he did not
with five members Sean with five members
not the one member to offer the motion
to vacate so my question is this how
many Pelosi's you haven't answered my
question so if you have yesterday you
supported responsibility yesterday you
supported Jordan today you're supporting
Donald that's not the way we need a
check and a balance on the third in line
who is your fight let's have a final
answer who do you want to be Speaker of
the House the conference to decide we
need to come together who do you want
I'm asking who you are what does it look
like after Kevin we would like to know
who can actually unify the Republican
party I have offered I would like to
know but some other folks start offering
there are 203 people and you have 20. I
respect the 20 of you I respect all of
you but I'm asking you based on your own
words as well who is your fine let's
have a final answer who do you want who
will you only support to be speaker
that's not that hard I'm willing to have
conversations with the Republican
conference to come up with a consensus
candidate we are offering people right
now it doesn't have to be a member of
the freedom caucus it doesn't even have
to be a solid but we have more than half
the freedom caucus supports McCarthy so
you don't have you don't even have a
name because they're and we're now going
into day three I'm afraid when you are
threatened by committee chairman to not
be placed by steering mirror let me ask
a final question it's your final if your
final candidate committee and then Kevin
McCarthy affirms that that's a scary
place to be we are here to legislate we
are here to get the country back on
track and I can tell you have people
making threats like that it's difficult
to make that decision but we are going
to get there I am fine doing this we're
in day two it's okay the government
isn't spending
um money sending it to Ukraine so the
American taxpayers are certainly winning
there's a politically congresswoman you
and I agree on most things we don't
disagree on many things Sean and and I I
do have respect for you but however I'm
on the right side of this shot well you
you can believe you're in your position
but I'm using your words you said to
president Trump you say we're very clear
he doesn't have
218 so you need to ask him to withdraw
if by Friday you and your group of 20
don't have a name with 30 votes is it
time for you to withdraw and if not why
do you support a double standard last
question
Kevin McCarthy does not have 218 votes
Kevin McCarthy and you have 20. I
I asked you a very specific question If
by Friday
not Sean I will not withdraw our asks
were were not Petty of Kevin McCarthy
they were not self-serving we simply
were asking for commitments on what the
American people want to see they want to
see a vote on term limits a vote on the
Texas border plan to secure the southern
border congresswoman we asked for a vote
on a budget that actually
imagine imagine
a Congress that stops
people supporting you right and we are
going to get the right speakers if you
only have 30 to be clear you will not
withdraw it's going to be a beautiful
name well you're telling Kevin McCarthy
and the and the 203 people that support
him to withdraw because they don't have
218. that's what you're saying
look it's obvious by tonight's most
motion to adjourn that Kevin McCarthy
and his supporters are already getting
voter fatigue and I asked you a simple
question congresswoman I I you know I
feel like I'm getting a liberal
McCarthy Sean
okay so even if you only have 30 votes
Kevin McCarthy you will not abide by
what you told president Trump
I feel like we've made progress
look I love president Trump you're not
going to turn me on him you're not going
to pit him against me I'm not trying to
pin him against you that's what you said
to him I am standing I have you're the
one that said a test I have seen the
lack of accountability
well we are we are getting phone calls
saying that we need to stop this Kevin
does not have the votes first I got her
period I need to find a consensus
candidate get this right and get our
country back on track thanks so much
Sean hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else